hey leute und herzlich willkommen zum
kurzen video wo ich mal ganz kurz meine
meinung zum parteitag und zwar ganz
ungeschnitten einfach nur ein katja
damit das wirklich so schnell wie
möglich online kommt weil mich regt das
in letzter zeit echt so dermaßen auf ne
ich bekomme zehn milliarden kommentare
täglich oder 100 milliarden irgendwas um
den dreh haye konnte die qualität ist so
schlecht hey warum ist der fall nicht
vorhanden hier das video lädt bei mir
gar nicht hey das gute video wird mehr
gar nicht in der box angezeigt hey ich
werde immer automatisch bei youtube
abgemeldet hey ich kann er keinen
kommentar schreiben hey ich kann das
video gar nicht bewerten diese funktion
ist nicht verfügbar
ich kann nichts dafür das ist dies
abgefuckte youtube es ist mir egal ob
dieses videos gesperrt oder nicht aber
es muss einfach mal gesagt werden
youtube geht den bach runter
ich verstehe es nicht ich weiß die
reißen sich den arsch ab und versuchen
das beste wie möglich draus machen
aber dieser box wird nur noch schlechter
werden keine uploads mehr richtig
angezeigt ein video von mir wurde mir
letztes als ich am zweit kanal drin war
wo ich die gleichen abos abonniert habe
damit einfach gucken kann wo mein video
ist wurde mit vor fünf tagen angezeigt
obwohl es an dem tag heute hochgeladen
wurde ich verstehe dieses prinzip nicht
hinter youtube was ist das denn was soll
das denn was machen die der den ganzen
tag
ich weiß die haben server des todes und
die ganze video gespeichert werden aber
warum und was ich von euch auch nicht
verstehe warum seid ihr da nicht so klug
und helfen dabei den leuten die das
irgendwie nicht verstehen weil ein paar
leute schreiben an die kommentare
hey wartet doch mal das dauert ist das
video verarbeitet weil wenn man ein
video hochlädt könnt ihr nicht erwarten
dass das video wenn es hochgeladen ist
direkt auf 180 milliarden pixel hd
verfügbar ist das kann ich direkt auf
720p seien youtube braucht seine zeit
das zu verarbeiten das brauch in letzter
zeit bei youtube immer so lockt haft
fünf sechs sieben acht stunden darüber
dena schon ein video gemacht dass eine
die lgt erfolge nicht verarbeitet wurde
darüber kann ich jetzt auch ein video
machen bei letztes von mir eine folge
auch nicht verarbeitet wurde das hat
einfach mal drei stunden gedauert bis hd
verfügbar war
bis dahin war die hälfte display
qualität obwohl ich nicht mehr was dafür
kann auch weltlichen teil hoch da steht
kann ich genommen werden ich musste mein
pc neu starten damit youtube diese
scheiße
genommen hat was von dem format kein
bisschen anders war als von der folge
davor man das ist eigentlich so eine art
drittes conny 30 grad aufnehmen das ist
einfach nur ich verstehe das nicht was
was ist mit youtube los warum ich meine
wenn die mal einen tag das haben dass
keine uploads angezeigt werden oder zwei
tagen ein ander oder nun haben sie mal
zwei wochen später wieder den fehler
dass man keine kommentare schreiben kann
dann ist es ja vollkommen okay das hat
jede website war das ist mal kurz die
funktioniert oder die server überlastet
sind irgendwie so aus aber das ist jetzt
schon seit ein zwei wochen dass keine
uploads richtig angezeigt werden dass
man nicht kommentare richtig schreiben
kann ich bin zum beispiel in meinem
konto eingeloggt will ein video
bearbeiten was sich zum beispiel heute
hochgeladen habe das mit dem was würdet
ihr machen wenn ihr zwei wochen sterben
würde dieses meinungs- video damit
vertritt will das bearbeiten und auf
einmal steht da du bist nicht mehr
eigentümer teil eines kontos ich
schreibe bei uns in der gruppe von mega
projekt rein
habt ihr den fehler auch hier habe ich
auch jojo was soll das ich meine was ist
los mit youtube wenn das im mittelalter
von youtube schießt was machst du bei
youtube was sollen das was ist das für
ein scheiß all das wirklich echt nur
noch auf ich habe keinen bock videos
machen wenn sie wenn sie keiner sieht
wenn keiner dieses videos sehen kann
wenn es wenn die leute sehen und die
wollen sich anklicken dann ist es deren
meinung aber wenn die ist es wenn jetzt
den abonnenten ja nicht mal in der
startbox angezeigt wird oder wenn sie
ein kommentar schreiben wollte das geht
nicht oder wenn ich es bearbeiten will
aber es geht nicht ich verstehe das
nicht so war das war erstmal meine
meinung und jetzt wenn ich noch einen
kommentar lese scheiß qualität oder ist
nicht da oder conny wie hast du geändert
oder will ich kein kommentar schreiben
bitte verleitet einfach auf dieses video
danke tschüss